time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio some of the big stories
in the national football even though dak
prescott is injured and won't play again
this season
his situation hovers over the cowboys
and everything about the cowboys hovers
over the national football league on
monday
team
ceo stephen jones
said that dak prescott will be the
quarterback
for the cowboys next year and into the
future even though the cowboys may have
a prime pick where they could select a
trevor lawrence or justin fields who
knows do you believe
this conclusive and clear position taken
by stephen jones that
dak will definitely be the guy
definitely be the guy and there's no way
they would consider taking one of the
top rookies if they're in position to do
so peter
i think it is most likely that dak is
their guy and there's absolutely no way
if you're stephen jones and you're on a
radio show in dallas fort worth that you
can even open the window a crack
to the fact that we might take somebody
in this draft if we've got the fourth
pick now look
there's a lot that's going to happen
between now
um you know when january 3rd when the
cowboys will play their final game of
the year theoretically
um and a lot can happen
you know the cowboys can end up anywhere
from two and 14 which i think is highly
unlikely
to somewhere in the vicinity of four or
five wins in which they would still have
a top ten draft pick but it wouldn't
probably be in position to get one of
the great quarterbacks
there's the cowboys have to consider
getting uh
drafting a quarterback
uh at a reasonable price for the next
four years
if they have that chance they would be
not doing their due diligence mike but
in my opinion
they're not going to be in position
unless they want to
do something and pillage
future drafts
it's going to be very hard for me to
think that the cowboys will be in
position to take one of the great
passers
not that anything anyone connected to
the nfl says is ever binding
i still don't like sending the message
that the option is off the table because
if they do end up in position to get
trevor lawrence or justin fields at the
top of the draft and they're thinking
about trading because they'd rather pay
dak prescott 37 million for one more
year than trevor lawrence
37 million or less for four years
yeah even if even if they choose
to to stick with dac
you want to be able to negotiate a
potential trade and your best trade
leverage is the joe burrow trade
leverage the bengals had and it was real
we want the guy if you can convince
people you want trevor lawrence or
justin fields maybe you get a hell of a
lot more in a trade than you otherwise
would so i'm just not a fan of
foreclosing your potential
paths you could take even though you do
have to say all the right things about
dak especially since he suffered that
gruesome injury and there's a lot of
sympathy that's flowing his way
i just
can't process the disconnect between all
the things that cowboys executives will
say about dak prescott and their chronic
failure
to write the check necessary to show
that they truly believe the things they
say peter
yeah i agree mike i i think that first
of all stephen jones is in an absolute
no-win position as i say you can't leave
the window open a crack however even
though you can't leave the window open
at crack i think behind the scenes
uh with you know with his dad and with
the people who run the scouting
department i think you have to tell
everyone in the building
prepare for all eventualities because
simply you simply don't know
and and mike this is more difficult than
just saying trevor lawrence 37 for four
versus dak prescott one year for four
this is also
how else you are going to affect your
salary cap what veterans you're going to
have to jettison
if you agree to bring dak prescott back
this is not only a quarterback question
yeah especially because that 37 million
dollar number applies no matter how low
the cap goes next year they have to
absorb that number to keep dac around
all right that's it for us we'll see you
next time for more pft on yahoo sports
have a great day
[Applause]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports